[musique]
Le duc est un espion basé sur une histoire vraie.
Alors qu'il faisait des recherches sur l'Agence de sécurité nationale, il a accidentellement parlé d'un espion nommé Heum Seong.
j'ai découvert
Y avait-il vraiment un tel espion dans votre pays d'origine ?
Y avait-il une usine comme celle-ci et j'étais curieux et j'ai obtenu la date d'entrée et de sortie c5
Je ne le savais pas du tout avant de faire ce film.
Qu'est-ce que ces choses se sont réellement passées ?
C'était incroyable, et je dois bien le transmettre au public.
Eh bien, j'en ai entendu parler une fois avec un sens de la mission.
Pourquoi y a-t-il 189 wons ?
C'est le début de l'histoire de la raison pour laquelle les cheveux sont en contact avec trois fois par jour.
Espionnage réel Je parle de cette bataille hautement psychologique entre l'autre partie et l'autre partie.
tu peux penser
Parce que l'ennemi général et la horde exigeaient que le récit procède d'une manière différente de l'action
Les conversations étaient très denses.
Nous avons dit que la cible de l'action riche et forte était le brouillard nuageux, nous avons donc mentionné le sexe.
Je ressens la même chose
Il y a beaucoup de choses appelées bénédictions générales.
L'histoire est une histoire qui peut fonctionner sur l'essence de personnes appelées espions.
je pensais que ce n'était pas
euh vidéo
Oh vraiment aller jusqu'à moi
Il y avait beaucoup d'affaires d'État, oui
Dans quelle mesure pouvez-vous inspecter Pyongyang en détail?
Une question qui semble être quelque part dans le monde réel vient maintenant de la Corée du Nord.
A commencer par quelques transfuges nord-coréens, 1
À l'intérieur du serpent Gajo, il y a maintenant une chose appelée transpiration.
J'ai reçu une partie du bâtiment du patrimoine culturel d'une société mère, j'ai donc économisé une grande partie, mais un pointeur
va falloir que je change un peu
J'ai décidé de la direction et j'ai travaillé dessus.
mais s'il te plaît
En tant qu'espion qualifié,
tu as un gros tempérament
Il n'y a rien de ridiculement dur dans le pad, et lorsque vous tenez deux personnes
Quand je l'ai vu au chapitre 2, j'ai aussi mis les 4 premières façons, donc je l'ai fait quand je l'ai vu.
Que puis-je dire sur le bon personnel et le directeur
À cause de cette position et de toi, je suis mariné pour apprendre
Comme le s5 commun est un peu faux
La bataille est basée sur les émotions des personnages. Vous pouvez regarder de plus près, mais la caméra
La discrimination n'a pas beaucoup bougé
Les classiques du cinéma vont commencer à s'écrire beaucoup, suivez-moi
un bien
Pour la première fois, il y avait un acteur qui a volé le Premier ministre, Hangjaeng-nim, était un senior.
Nous devions avoir un visage qui n'était pas le rythme cardiaque rugueux de "Bien et Mal" et l'écorce de mandarine du bien et du mal
Prouver pourquoi il est Hwang Jung-min à chaque instant
C'est bon
Ah, je pensais que c'était un sniping par un client senior.
J'y travaille, mais la poésie de Seo Dong-hoon est avec le jambon que nous avions qui a bien fonctionné.
Collusion sans place pour rien
Merci de l'affiner en tant que candidat, en tant qu'acteur, vous deviendrez l'Agence de Promotion
Ce film, qui a été une aubaine de coopération avec Cho Jin-woong, n'a presque aucune tension.
Je pensais que c'était quand j'étais à mon apogée
Ryu Ji-hoon a le sentiment de faire le fil qu'il a appris.
Je pensais que ce serait différent avec une chienne très humoristique qui a été courtisée
Choisissez-vous exactement la personne que vous voulez photographier?
La 5ème place est en pleine floraison à chaque fois, donc c'est très persistant
C'est une personne, c'est une certaine chose à propos de vous-même, et c'est à côté de vous
Je suppose que tu y as pensé avec moi et que tu as ouvert ton cœur.
Ce travail est un jeu qui est très aggloméré.
Je suis sûr qu'il y en a, pour protéger quelque chose, nous devons nous battre comme ça
Maintenant il y a un putter
aaa sur
wow
[musique]
Il est écrit en anglais, qui est encore en développement nucléaire dans la section poivre.
j'ai peur d'essayer
Maintenant, allez bien Paju, où ils ne portent rien pour s'étendre à la classe de puissance nord-coréenne
#3
Réponse Jusqu'au jour où Pyongyang s'effondre, jusqu'au jour où l'on se retrouve au fleuve Taedong
Axo Kyong-seong, Congrès de l'économie de la République populaire démocratique de Corée
Merveille avec cet argument
[musique]
Avant la stratégie, la véritable identité sort sur la lune. Lee Soo-kyung
Le gouvernement et le NSP vont tout nier, il semble qu'il se passe quelque chose.
Un espion sud-coréen qui l'a trompé
Mentionné 15 points goût cool
ah
[musique]